Pamela Cox and I just moderated the
session selling the seeds of sustainable
food production in Latin America I think
we had a very lively panel necessarily
always stay on the topic but
nevertheless has contributed a lot of
discussion what we're looking at is
really how Latin America can be part of
the solution was solving global
we looked at issues such as price
volatility impact sustainability on
issues such as technology it was
interesting in all the interventions and
some of the questions have been raised
by the audience is that some of the
issues really don't have as much to do
with production as
other issues I think for example
logistics infrastructure are very
important latin america has very very
high-cost food both departments
to export we're reminded that we need
technology appropriate technology we
were also reminded that trade
liberalization is very important so we
issued for Latin America yes latin kings
of Egypt where people can produce a lot
of loot and exported to the rest of the
world
what people talked about water we need
to take water into the house and finally
I think several people reminded us that
these problems are not just government
problems that are also problems where
the private sector needs to partner we
had some examples from partnering on
technology sharing technology between
private
sectors and also on the infrastructure
side we closed with an exhortation to
say that we have to stop talking about
these issues and you now need to face
some and resolving